Wohl eines der größten rätsel der physik oder das verrät allein schon ihr name denn einzig
Omg also oh my god
hatten sich die wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler 1991 einfallen lassen als sie diese teilchen entdeckt hatten ihr
ursprungsort blieb bis jetzt ein großes rätsel
Doch jetzt ist klar die strahlung stammt aus fernen galaxien und ihre energie ist so unfassbar und erschreckend hoch milliardenfach
So schnell wie andere
Gewöhnliche teilchen aus dem all ihr habt euch dieses thema bei whatsapp gewünscht und bekommt jetzt alle wichtigen facts zu diesem kuriosen
teilchen welche fundamentalen erkenntnisse verraten sie über den ursprung des universums und können sie uns gefährlich werden
jetzt den klicks zum science fiction herzlich willkommen
Ja also wir sind hier übrigens bei how to music und das ist neues musikformat dass ich produziere tut mir einen gefallen abonniert unbedingt diesen
Kanal es wird sensationell wir begleiten sechs musikerinnen und musiker auf dem weg zu ihrer karriere ja wir haben ja öfter schon hier darüber berichtet
Unentwegt erreicht kosmische strahlung die atmosphäre konkret handelt es sich um schneller an tobt gerne
verschiedener chemischer elemente vor allem die sonne sendet kosmische teilchen den sogenannten sonnen wenn sie erreichen energien um die
100 millionen elektronenvolt das kann auf der erde zu störungen führen beispielsweise in der stromversorgung und im funkverkehr doch die
Sogenannten oh my god teilchen übertreffen wirklich alles von solch einem teilchen getroffen zu werden würde sich wohl anfühlen wie von einem
Richtig hart geschlagenen baseball doch dazu kommt es sicher nicht. Denn a
Sind die teilchen eher selten und b werden sie durch die atmosphäre in ihrer unfassbaren energie
Abgebremst doch erst jetzt konnte aus ein team
Aus mehr als 40 forscherinnen und forschern aus 18 ländern ihre konkreten ursprung nachweisen die teilchen gelangen demnach von
entfernten außer galaktischen objekten zur erde jenseits unserer milchstraße das zeigt die analyse der messdaten die von dem argentinischen
Per order observatorium stammen zitat diese neuen erkenntnisse werden es uns ermöglichen
fundamentale fragen über die entstehung des universums der milchstraße und anderen galaxien
Zu klären das sagt der beteiligte astrophysiker karl heinz kemper den gemessenen rekord hält an teilchen mit rund
303 millionen elektronenvolt
dieselbe energie also die ein schnell geschlagen oder tennis oder baseball hat
Omg also wahrsten sinne des wortes das argentinische auf story und besteht aus unvorstellbaren
1600 detektoren die auf einer fläche von
3.000 quadratkilometern verteilt sind das ist größer als das bundesland saarland es gibt
1600 messstationen jeweils einen detektor und zwölf tonnen wasser fassen
das wasser dient tatsächlich der energiemessung dabei macht sich das forschungsteam zunutze dass die teilchen der kosmischen strahlung mit luftmolekülen
Zusammen prasseln diese werden zerschmetterte ihre bruchstücke
Kollidieren weiter es entsteht eine lawine aus zeichen und die energie der ursprünglichen teilchen teilt sich auf treffen diese sehr
energiereichen teilchen auf das wasser in den tanks bewegen sie sich dort schneller als das licht normalerweise
Im wasser dazu kampert das kann man sich ähnlich vorstellen über ein flugzeug das die schallmauer dürfte
Zudem wenden sie licht aus die so genannte sprengkopf strahlung die kann dann durch die detektoren
nachgewiesen werden die ankunftszeit der teilchen lawine an den verschiedenen messstationen hilft dem forschungsteam zu bestimmen
Aus welcher richtung sie gekommen sind und zwar bis zu einem grad genau
Dennoch ist es kaum möglich die exakte quelle zu bestimmen denn ihr wisst im all
existieren unzählige
Kosmische magnetfelder durch die die teilchen abgelenkt werden nur wenn die teilchen
Höhere energien haben kommen sie nicht ab vom kurs doch wie schon gesagt?
omg teilchen mit derart hohen energien kommen nur selten auf der erde an
schätzungen zufolge fällt pro jahr 100 solcher teilchen auf die fläche eines
fußballfeldes doch die fläche des observatoriums groß genug um viele hoher energetischer
teilchen zu analysieren für die aktuelle studie wurden die messdaten von zehn jahren berücksichtigt jetzt steht noch ein feinschliff an
Denn bisher werden alle kosmischen teilchen berücksichtigt doch da sie
unterschiedlich schwere atomkern haben fliegen verschiedene teilchen extrem unterschiedlich reisen beispielsweise
Weniger geradlinig als helium kerne wenn demnächst also die schweren atomkerne herausgefiltert werden könnte dies ein
schärferes bild der genauen quellen liefert wenn er als erstes dazu also zum thema der um die teilchen und zu allen an
Thema erfahren wollt dann endet meine telefonnummer bei whatsapp hier ist der link dazu
Dann erfahrt ihr von mir vor allen anderen vom neuesten video garantiert ihr könnt dort
Direkt über mich in der redaktion vom klick zum mitmachen und tut mir den gefallen ist wird wirklich ein hammer
projekt hier auto music in berlin sechs
Nachwuchsmusikerinnen und musiker auf dem weg zum erfolg die begleiten mehr und das wird wirklich spannend ja und ansonsten würde ich mal sagen
dafür das abo nicht vergessen und die glocke
Genau die müsste unbedingt leuten und hier geht es weiter mit dafür auch. Draufklicken neues teilchen entdeckt ansonsten bis dann
bleibt da